l'anniversaire de ce grand jour est
célébrée sous la plage darroman ici a
commencé la fin de la guerre juin 1945
un an après le débarquement alors que la
guerre n'est même pas fini
une cérémonie a lieu en présence des
combattants français et de l'ambassadeur
britannique
ces plages seront à jamais un lieu de
mémoire
trente quatre ans plus tard en 1979
ce tourisme de mémoire étonné ce
journaliste
c'est inscrit dans l'histoire et dans
les habitudes qui dit plage dormantes
pense aujourd'hui débarquement par le
secteur attraction je ne trouve pas
d'autres mots pour ce qui est des
retombées des grands événements
historiques et de leur exploitation
touristique qu'il s'agisse de verdun ou
de la normandie les touristes de
l'époque beaucoup d'anciens combattants
français anglais mais aussi allemands ce
sont des hommes avant tout qu'ils
reviennent sur leurs souvenirs
alors bien sûr ou la nationalité de
mumbai c'est un combattant il a vécu la
même chose quand même
mais ce tourisme va connaître un coup
d'accélérateur en 1984 pour le 40e
anniversaire du 10 d une grande
cérémonie internationale est organisée
place des villages ayant vécu le
débarquement sont alors dépoussiérer et
surtout les lieux historiques on nettoie
les barges et même les bunkers du mur de
l'atlantique un coup de neuf pour les
charrs humide pour la première fois un
président américain fait le déplacement
pour la cérémonie avec lui trente mille
vétérans ce 40e anniversaire va donc
avoir des retombées directes au mois de
juin ne de l'année dernière nous
faisions umih entrées et au mois de juin
de cette année nous avons fait 28
d'entrée la région met un point
d'honneur à entretenir ces lieux de
mémoire mais ne perd pas de vue les
retombées économiques de ce tourisme
alors des infrastructures sont mises en
place le mémorial de caen est inaugurée
en 88 et en 1993 la région modernise
tous les sites touristiques le tourisme
lié la seconde guerre mondiale apparaît
comme l'un des éléments incontournables
de l'économie bas normands plus les
années passent et plus le nombre de
touristes augmente il était 2,9 millions
en 1995 4,6 millions en 2017
et chaque année anniversaire
l'engouement des touristes est relancé
car si au lendemain de la guerre les
touristes étaient des anciens
combattants aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
cas on souhaitait venir un jour ici un
oeil l'assurance on est là c'est
tellement impressionnant est beau la
région veut maintenir ce tourisme de
mémoire en s'adaptant aux nouveaux
profils des touristes
le numérique pourrait être un outil mais
aussi l'inscription des plages du
débarquement au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
[Musique]